JAMAL EASON: We're
happy to launch,
last December,
Android Studio 1.0.
So since launch, the
majority of our users
have made the transition
over to Android Studio.
So if you haven't
had the time, now
is a good time to
make that transition.
Our team is fully focused on
working on Android Studio,
and we're constantly
listening to your feedback.
We want you to make
the features that
work best for you and your
development environment.
So when we launched
Android Studio 1.0,
we asked you developers,
hey, what do you what?
We did a survey, and this
is what sort of panned out
from those results.
Number one, a lot of people
asked about Design Tools.
Number two, a faster
Emulator Experience.
Number three, NDK support.
And number four, app testing.
And we really appreciated
hearing all this feedback,
so we can really
prioritize our work
to making sure we do the right
stuff that works for you.
So in this talk, we'll talk
about three different types
of tools that we've be working
on for the last couple months.
We'll talk a little
bit about design,
a little bit about
developing and tests,
and we'll cap it off
of the demo showcasing
the work that we've been
working on in Android Studio.
So design-- so Chet talked about
this a little bit in the what's
new section, but as you know,
we launched Material Design
with Android 5.0.
And I'm really excited about
this Android Design Support
Library, because what
it allows you to do
is really focus on your content.
Instead of worrying about
meeting the specs of material
design, you can literally
drag and drop these components
into your application,
and you're
on your way to having a
high quality application.
And as we've talked
before, we've
included a few elements--
things like the Floating Action
Button, the Toolbar
with Motion--
so that's the toolbar you see
with a lot of Google Apps that,
sort of, expand grow.
Now that is for free.
You can now drag in that
into your application.
We've also include the Snack
Bar, the Navigation View,
and Text Input.
And of course, as always,
it's backwards compatible,
Meaning that if you target
Android L and higher,
you can still get that
same material look and feel
for all your previous
applications.
[APPLAUSE]
And so Vector Images.
So last year, as well, we
introduced Vector Drawables
with Lollipop.
Now I don't know
about you, it's really
kind of painful to manage an
update-- lots of raster images
and bitmaps across
different densities.
And so see, with Android Studio,
you can now import an SVG file
or work directly with
the vector drawable.
And during build time, we will
generate all the assets for you
automatically.
[APPLAUSE]
So, if you're not
aware, if you wanted
to change an asset
or some sizing,
you just change the
vector drawable,
and we'll build that
for the PNG asset.
And a couple things that
this helps you with.
Hopefully it saves
you time and hassle
in generating all these assets.
And then, lastly, hopefully
decrease your APK size.
In many cases, if you just
include a vector drawable,
you can add a tint to
it and it increase--
sorry it decreases your
APK size for most apps.
And then, lastly, for
divisional design editors.
So looking at the
results of the survey,
we thought about how do we help
you design your application?
We know a lot of
you enjoy, maybe,
working directly with XML.
But for me, and a
lot of developers,
I like using visual tools
to do visual elements
of my application.
So we pretty much looked
at all different files
you had to work with-- things
like styles.xml, colors.xml--
and came to the conclusion
that, well, you know, we
need to write it from scratch.
And so we're going
to show you today
a few demos of the work we've
been doing to make it easier
for you to maintain
easier UI, without having
to solely rely on using XML
to work with your UI elements.
And so with that,
I'll transition
to Xav to talk a little bit
about our development tools.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Thank you, Jay.
All right, so core
to our strategy
is our unified build system.
So whether you're building from
Studio from the command line
or from your build
server, you're
going to use a single build
and that's based on Gradle.
So since 1.0, we
focused on a few items.
The first one was correctness.
We fixed a lot of bugs first.
And a lot of those issues
were on dependency management.
For example, for properly
handling the test dependencies.
When you have an
application and a test that
have the same dependency,
you need to make sure
that you only package it once.
There's a lot of corner cases
there that we had to support,
so we dumped a lot of those.
So if you had some issues, you
can upgrade to a later version.
We've also added support--
we also fixed a lot of issue
regarding the provided scopes.
And new in 1.3, we
are adding support
for optional dependencies
in library projects.
The other thing that we're
focusing a lot on right
now is performance.
And we know that's on
a lot of your minds.
And so there's really two
aspects to performance.
The first one is just
the build steps, right,
like the compilation steps, the
DX steps, the packaging steps.
So here we have a few
different things going on.
The first one is we have these
new compiler called Jack.
And Jack is a compiler
that's replaced DX
and goes directly from Java
source code to DEX file.
We've already had a first
preview a few months back.
And so we'll have a
new preview in 1.3
with both the new
version of Jack
and a new version
of our plug in that,
offering incremental support
when you're building.
And in some of our tests we've
seen some good performance
increase in that step.
Which is one,
probably, of the steps
that takes the longest time.
[APPLAUSE]
We're also looking
at other steps
that we are doing
and improving them.
So for example, the
PNG cruncher is one
that we fixed, starting
with build tools 22.
We looked at it
and the old one--
if you did-- you
know if you had about
500 PNGs in your
application-- and they
need to be processed
in order to be packaged
with your application,
especially
if they are nine patches--
500 PNG could take, like,
four seconds and we are
down to 400 milliseconds.
So it's much better.
[APPLAUSE]
And then, finally,
APT, which is the tool
and that packages is all of your
resources, create binary XML,
and all of that-- we
are working heavily
to actually make the stapler so
incremental, because right now,
it always recompile
all of your resources.
So that's the first
aspect the performance--
the signal aspect
is Gradle itself.
And we know that, right
now, when you build,
you get a feeling that it
takes a long time to start up,
and you know, it's like,
what is going, right?
So the thing that Gradle
does when you start
is it creates a model of your
project-- of every single
of your module,
it's going to create
a model that contains all the
variant created from build
types and product flavors.
It's going to create the task
to build every single one
of your variant.
It's going to resolve
all of the dependencies
for every single one
of your variants.
And it's like-- if it's
a lot of work, right?
And then if you
have custom logic,
it's going to run that
custom logic every time.
And your custom logic
could tweak the model,
could tweak the task, add new
task, and do things like that.
So let's look at an example.
Here we have a
project that has 10
modules with 25 variant each.
One the first
line, the help task
does nothing build related.
It just output a static text.
And then the second line,
assemble one variant.
So by assemble here, we
actually run that benchmark
with the dry run mode,
where it actually
skips all the build steps,
like the compilation
and the packaging.
So we really look at the time
that Gradle itself takes.
And you can see that
on those two lines--
it's the same exact
amount of time.
And that's because
Gradle is a little bit--
that it's not very smart here.
It doesn't really know that
they help task is not really
build related.
And so it's still to
build all of that model.
And then the third
line we're running
every variant of every module,
and that takes a bit more time,
because in the end you
still have a bigger task
graph that needs to be
prepared and run through.
And then the two column that
we have-- so the first column
is Gradle plug-in 1.0
with Gradle 2.2.1,
which is a minimum requirement.
And the second one is 1.2
with, also, Gradle 2.2.1.
And you can see here that
we, actually, we're not going
in the right direction here.
And that's because
we're doing more things.
I mentioned a lot about more
dependency management check,
support, test, and scope.
And that's just more
work equals longer time.
And that's really not
what we what to do.
So we worked very
closely with Gradleware,
the company behind Gradle,
to solve the problem.
And so we did a lot of
optimization and with Gradle
1-- the plug-in 1.3 and with
Gradle 2.4, which was just
released like a few weeks ago.
And so, the numbers
already look much better.
[APPLAUSE]
Let's look at another example.
This project here is a single
module with 400 variants.
Now this is really
a corner case.
Not a lot of people would have
400 variants in their project,
I hope.
And clearly, when you look
at the time, it's pretty bad.
Definitely some
scalability issue.
So if we look at the
result, that's even better.
[APPLAUSE]
So if you notice though--
in that case-- in both
of those cases,
if you will still
run only help or
a single variant,
that's still about the
same amount of time.
We haven't solved that issue
of Gradle still building
the whole model.
And so we've been-- for
the past year or so,
we've been working very
closely with the Gradle team
to fix that problem.
They've been
working on a new API
to build plug-in
that will solve this.
So on top of that--
on top those new APIs,
we are building a next
generation plug-in.
And the goal here
is to have Gradle
be more involved in the model
that our plug-in creates.
Basically Gradle is going
to manage that model for us.
It's going to manage the
variants and the task
and all that, in
order to do less.
The goal here is to
make Gradle do only
what's needed to build what
you requested to build.
And then because Gradle
also managed that model,
it can cache it and
make incremental upgrade
to the cache when only
some things have changed.
And then finally It
will have also opened
the door for more optimization.
For example, right now, if you
have a multi-module project,
every single module you is
evaluated sequentially--
there's no parallelism.
So that's something
we can improve.
So let's look at
the new numbers.
That's even better, right.
And what you notice here is
that when you run just the help
task on a small project,
those 0.9 signals
is really what it takes.
When you run them from the
command line to start Gradle,
have it communicate with
a demand, out to the text,
and then quit.
It's basically the
doing nothing else.
And when you start building
only a single variant,
it's just a little
bit more time.
And the difference between
building a single variant
and building all the
variants is actually
bigger than in the previous case
because that's the case where
suddenly we do a lot more.
The interesting point--
oh, big caveat here,
there is no caching in here.
They haven't implemented,
yet, caching.
So you can see that those number
will get even smaller when
you're building all the variance
and the model has been cached.
All we have to do is
reload it from the cache,
and so that will be even faster.
The interesting point
here is that when
you're building from
Studio, when you do deploy,
you're actually building
a single variant
from a single module.
Plus [INAUDIBLE] dependencies.
So it's really the best
scenario where you only
have Gradle do the minimum
that it needs to do.
And so that will
really speed up your
build when you're developing
from within Studio.
So what's the deal
with the new plug-in?
The first thing to
know is that it's
new APIs-- the DSL
will be-- so the DSL is
the language that you use to
drive the build at Gradle 5.
It will be slightly
different, and that's
because Gradle,
as I said earlier,
managed part of the model.
So we have to use a DSL
that works with those APIs.
We're going to ship that as a
preview in 1.3 in a few weeks.
It's not part of the current
1.3 release that we did today.
Just a week or two and
we'll release a preview.
And then from then on, we'll
keep releasing, as a preview,
alongside 1.3, 1.4, et cetera.
Still as a preview--
alongside the old plug-in
that will still be there.
And then later this year that
we'll replace, officially,
the current plug-in.
If you're using Studio,
whether you're using,
the old plug-in or the new
plug-in, it doesn't matter.
They work the same with Studio.
Studio doesn't care.
It's the same model
that's exposed to the ID.
So that's on the
performance side.
Let's talk at little
bit about Data Binding.
You probably heard
about that already
in the previous session.
So we have Data Binding.
It's purely build time.
All you have to do is
set up your build system
and then it will just
generate the code for you,
and then it just works.
There is a support library
also that's part of that.
So right now it's part
of a separate plug-in,
and then, hopefully,
for 1.3 we will
include that in the main
plug-in so that you don't even
have to go and install
another plug-in.
So for now though you have
to install that plug-in.
It's available on launch center.
You install that
plug-in, then you
start adding Date Binding
event in your resources,
and that's it.
It adds the dependency
for you-- nothing to do.
It will just do
what it has to do.
NDK C/C++ Support-- Gradle has
support for Native Support now.
And so we are building a
new integration in Gradle
based on that.
And because it's somewhat tied
to the new component model
that-- those new API I
just talked about-- that's
going to be tied to the
next generation plug-in
we're working on.
And that will allow us to--
that integration in Gradle
will allow us to have a really
good integration in studio
where everything
that Studio needs
to know about your project for
editing we come from Gradle,
and then we'll have a
great experience there.
And so for the
experience in Studio,
we really wanted to provide
the best possible experience
for editing and debugging.
And so we partnered with
JetBrains to package,
in Studio, their brand new ID
for C/C++ directly in Studio
and it will be free for
Android development.
I don't know if you--
[APPLAUSE]
We did not want to
start from scratch.
They have a great solution, and
we are just offering it to you.
And you have full
debugging, full refactoring.
It's really a great tool.
All right, so, let's talk a
little bit about testing now.
So since 1.0 we added a
few features for testing.
The first one that we added
was unit test support.
So, what I mean by
unit test support
here is unit test that
worked directly natively
on the desktop JVM, rather than
having to be compiled into NPK
and sent to the device.
That's to speedup
round tripping-- your
fixing your bugs-- your bugs and
your test and seeing results.
The big point here
is that this is not
meant to run Android platform
code on the Desktop JVM.
We do provide a custom
Android Java where
you can go and mock everything.
The normal Android
Java, actually,
has a lot of class
that are final.
So we can upstream
the final or so
that you can go and mock them.
But you have to
mock what you use.
So it's strictly for
your business logic.
It's up to you to figure out how
much you want to mock on out.
The goal is not to
replace [INAUDIBLE] here.
But if you want to use
that-- just opening
your test in source test Java.
There's unique test
specific dependencies
and you can just add that, and
then you can run your test.
The other thing that we
added in Gradle-- in 1.3--
is External Test Project.
We had a lot of
developer telling us
that they wanted more
flexibility in how
they organize their
app and their test.
And they wanted to make the
test in a different module.
So you can now do that.
That test project
targets a specific module
and a specific variant
of that module.
There's no support for flavors
or variant in a test module.
If you want a test
multiple variant
of your same
application, you have
to use different
test module for now.
And those features
are really like part
of our overarching
story of improving
testing story on Android.
So it goes from
Studio and Gradle
having better support at the
project level and in the tools.
Having better
testing libraries--
Espresso, the Android Testing
Library, the Unit Test support,
and all that.
Then the test lab
that we announced
this morning, all the
way to which we in
have in play-- the play console
about testing your application.
And our goal is to
make it very easy
for you to write tests,
run them-- right,
that's very important too--
to help you make high quality
application.
Part of making high
quality application
is also performance.
And so when investing a lot
and adding things into studio,
since 1.0 we added a live
CPU and memory profiling.
And then, in 1.3 we're
announcing a new viewer
to view your memory heap.
We'll have a demo
of that letter.
Emulator-- so, we've mostly been
focused on stability in order
to enable performance.
Now if properly configured, and
running on a compatible system,
the Emulator can
actually be fast.
The prime is making
sure that most people
can run the properly
configured Emulator.
And so we've been
looking a lot at adding--
helping you configure it.
So for example,
Studio out of the box
will now install-- download
and install HAXM for you
in order to run it, you
know, at native speed on x86.
The AVD manager
will automatically
configure it for you.
And the other thing that
we've done recently-- we've
fixed literally thousands of
issues in the GL renderer-- the
how to our GL renderer
Because if you're
forced to move to
the software renderer
because you're graphic
driver isn't compatible,
the experience is much worse.
So we've done a
lot of improvement
there in order to help
you, basically, run
as fast as it can be.
And then, specifically,
for M we're
adding some new features like
the fingerprint emuation--
where you can add fingerprints,
register fingerprint, and then
use them when your
application request them.
Talking about Emulator,
later this year we're
going to launch a new Emulator
specifically for Android Auto.
So it will be a
head unit Emulator.
You will be able to take either
an Android-- like a phone
emulator or physical
device-- just connect them
to your machine and then
the head unit will basically
show what you would see on
a car with Android Auto.
All right and I give
it to Tor for demos.
TOR NORBYE: All right, who
wants to see the C++ report?
[APPLAUSE]
All right, can we switch
to-- yes, you already have.
So this is C++.
You remember pointers?
So what you're looking at here
is a game that's been written
in C++.
And as you can see, the source
editor is fully aware of that.
It's warming us that these
include statements are actually
unused, because none of
the symbols in the Include
are actually used
in the source file.
So I can invoke the action
to just clean that up,
and that gets rid of that.
I can use the normal
navigation commands.
So with F12 I can filter
and jump to the right method
that I'm looking for.
I can use the action to jump
to related symbol, which
will navigate to the
header file prototype.
And I can use that to jump back.
Yay!
I can use the action to
jump to the super method.
I can also use find usages.
So if I do find usages
on the symbol right here,
you can see it's doing and non
textual-- an actual accurate
search through the symbols.
And related to find usages,
of course, is refactoring.
So I can do a rename on
this method, right here.
Get instance-- let's
call it, get singleton.
And when I do that the
ID-- it looks at everything
and discovers that, hey, there's
some textual occurrences.
Do you want those as well?
So I can pull up the
show usages window.
Here I can see that we
have some text files that
are using this API,
but I don't, actually,
want to include those
in the refactoring.
So I'll just delete it.
And then we have all the
accurate matches here.
So I can just apply the
refactoring, and voila,
change has been made in C++.
All right, as you can
see here the editor
is also doing things
like telling me
that this symbol is unused.
Actually, let's
just use it instead.
So we have code completion.
And I can use the
normal stuff you're
used to from Java
programming, where you type
some of the capital letters.
So if I type O, P, M-- it's
matching on pointer move,
and I can, then, insert
that and perform--
insert whatever the parameters
are that I need for this method
call.
Furthermore, them I can
select some expressions,
and I can extract
this into a variable.
It picks a suitable name for me.
Or I can go in, in-line
it back into the code,
and it'll do that.
And take a look at this here,
I have two local variables.
I can actually extract
this into a method.
And even though I have multiple
outputs from this method,
that's not a problem in C++
because it can just do pass
by reference.
So if I now jump
in here, you can
see that we have the
variables passed in.
So the key thing here is that
this is not just a port of all
the Java features of C++.
They have a lot of unique
C++ features as well.
So for a factory,
for example, I can
extract into macros-- I
can extract type typedefs
and so forth.
So there's a lot of C++ features
that I could get into and I
could spend the
whole demo on that--
on code styles and formatting,
on intentions, inspections.
We have a debugger.
We support GDB and LLDB.
I just want to show
one more thing,
and this is,
specifically, for those
of you doing JNI development
with the Android NDK.
So let me jump into my JNI file.
So here is a JNICALL.
So if I do find
usages on this method,
you can see that it's
highlighting not just the C
code, but also the native
declaration in Java,
as well as calls to
that Java method.
[APPLAUSE]
And notice that there's
this little icon
and then you might
be able to see,
but this is for jumping
between related symbols.
So just like I can jump between
an implementation and a header
file, I can use
the same keystroke
to jump between JNI method
and the declaration.
And look what happens if
I break this signature.
If I type in some
random thing here
and I go back to
Java-- you could
see now we know in editor, this
is no longer a valid binding.
And this is actually
really good way
for me to create
new Native methods.
I just make the method
declaration that I want.
Let's make it a little
more interesting
to input some parameters into
it like a string and an integer
array.
And now there's a
quick fix, which
will create the
right JNI binding,
insert it into the C code--
[APPLAUSE]
And you can see, we're also
inserting things like, hey,
we're passing you a
Java unicode string.
It will convert that
into a const char
for C. Ditto for erase, and then
don't forget to release them
when you're done.
So we hope the
feature will make it
a lot easier to work with JNI.
Now I want to jump over
to discuss editing Java.
So let's see, today we
are releasing-- actually
I think we already released it.
There's a new version
of the Support Library.
And it has the Design
Library, and so forth.
But there are now
13 new annotations
you can use in your code to,
basically, catch more bugs.
And we've used these annotations
in the Android framework
and the support libraries
to catch your bugs, as well.
So first of all, there's
some threading annotations.
So here we're saying that
this method is a worker thread
method.
That means we expect it be
called in a worker thread.
And we've already annotated the
framework with the knowledge
that view code has to be
invoked in the UI thread.
So we can instantly
tell here, hey, you're
calling a UI thread method from
a worker thread-- that's bad.
And you don't have to go and put
worker thread on your own code
because we've already done it.
For example, AsyncTask.
If you make an
AsyncTask, and you
do something in the
doInBackground method,
notice there's no
annotation here.
We still flag this code
as, well, this one's
supposed to be called
on the main thread.
And this one, you
know, UI thread.
So that's the
threading annotations.
There's the size annotation.
Here you can say things like,
well, I want this string
to be a certain length
or this an array
to be a certain size--
maybe max, maybe
an exact number, maybe a min.
Or you could even
say, multiple of.
So if you take an array, and you
want it to be XYZ coordinates,
you could say multiple of three.
So here for example I'm
passing a string that's
too long for this constraint.
And here, we're passing an
array that is of the wrong size.
So similar to size we have int
and range-- int range and float
range annotations.
Here you can say that
this value needs to be
in this constrained range.
This is really useful
for things like alpha.
So it turns out
that for image view,
the alpha value is a integer
between zero and 255.
But for view, it's a floating
point between zero and one.
So what we're doing here is,
I thought, opacity-- 128.
That should be half
opacity, right?
That's correct for Image
View but not for Button.
And so this,
basically, tells you
that you're passing a parameter
that's not the right range.
Check results--
basically you can
use this to tell the client code
that they better do something
with the return value.
And call super
says that if anyone
overwrites your method they
better invoke super dot method.
And then there's color
int, which is used to say,
this integer represents a color.
And we'll see that
a little bit later.
Last but not least--
requires permission.
So this let's you, say, that
a certain method requires
a particular permission.
Or maybe all of a
set of permissions,
or any of a set of permissions.
So we've already
added to the framework
with some of these
permission requirements.
So for example,
Location Manager--
if I'm trying to invoke
at last known location,
we will say that, hey, you
don't hold the right permissions
for this method call.
Would you like to add them?
Yes, I would.
So there's a quick fix for that.
And so I can say please add the
find location to my manifest.
And so I do that, but sadly
there's still the red line.
What does that line mean?
Well if you watched the
keynote this morning,
M is, basically, now supporting
revocable permissions.
So here, because my
app is targeting M,
this method can throw
security exception,
even though I specifically
requested the permission
in the manifest.
So what I should do is actually
check for the permission first.
So we track that I'm not
actually doing that check,
and there's a quick
fix to add it.
Which, basically, looking at
the permission requirements
will add the right
checks and also suggest
what you should do
if you really want
to ask the user with
the callback, and all
that good stuff.
So that's the static analysis.
We're also taking that
into the debugger.
So here I am in the middle
of debugging this code.
And you can see here I'm looking
at this variable here-- flags.
It's a local variable
and the value is five.
What this five mean?
Anyone?
Well let's ask the debugger.
So I can right click
on this and say view
as Android type integer.
And when I do that--
[APPLAUSE]
So for those of you
who didn't clap,
let me show you
what just happened.
Basically this local variable--
we traced this to this field.
We look at the field.
We see that it has a getter.
We see that the getter
has a type annotation.
The type annotation says that
we had these possible constants.
And we check the constants
and find the ones that match.
And that's how we produced this.
So that's pretty neat.
[APPLAUSE]
And this is not
just for typedefs.
For example, here I have
another integer field
which-- minus 65,408-- I don't
know if that rings a bell,
but I can ask it to do a
type conversion on this one.
Oh, it's a color.
Because color int puts the
annotation that we saw earlier,
and that's been an annotated.
Text ID is another
one of those integers,
and I can convert this one.
And it figures out, well,
that's a resource string
and it corresponds to this
specific string object.
[APPLAUSE]
So that's a new feature.
I hope you'll find that useful.
Now I'm going to show you Data
Binding very, very briefly.
So here I am in an activity.
And this activity-- I
actually have a layout
called main activity
in my project.
If you ever made
a Studio project,
you probably have one, too.
And so the Gradle
plug-in actually
creates this class
main activity binding,
which takes all the
fields in your layout
and produces getters-- or
actually field accessors.
You can see here I have
something called Robot list.
I forgot to tell you, the
Data Binder is done here.
Here we're actually associating
this activity with this layout.
So once I've done that,
we get these magic fields.
And these are just
IDs in my layout.
If I do go to declaration,
I jump right into my layout.
You can see it's just a recycler
view and robot list is just
the ID.
So if I change that ID to
something else, and I go back,
you could see now that it knows,
hey, that's not the right field
on this class anymore.
This is a dynamically
generated code.
So I can go and fix it.
And there's code completion
on this, as well, of course.
So that's the Binder.
This handles all the fine
findViewByID binding for you.
You now longer have to do that.
You get getters and setters
and everything is handled
in the thread safe correct way.
So if I look in the
layout file, you
can see here that there's
a bunch of new tags.
I can create variables.
And I can even do imports.
And I can alias them,
so I have simpler thing
to refer to in my code below.
And then, in the layout,
I can do things like this.
I can take methods, like
the onts-- all the setters
and getters on the views are
accessible here as properties,
and, likewise, on the activity.
And I can also compute value.
So I can bind the
Android text attribute
to this expression,
which is using
the variable I declared
above and mapping
two properties Natively.
So this takes out a lot
of the Plumbing Code,
and I can't actually do
this justice in 90 seconds.
But it's available
now, so please, try it.
[APPLAUSE]
So now my talk about
performance for a second.
So as Xav showed
in the screenshot,
you can go and capture
performance snapshots here,
now, in the Android view,
from your connected device.
And once you do
that, we basically
show the performance data files
here in the captures view.
So you can, basically,
accumulate them
here for later
analysis, or if you
want to compare two
different captures.
So let me first open up
the allocation tracker.
So here I can see
that for this capture,
thread one was responsible
for most of their RAM--
or most of the allocations.
And I can start drilling in
here to see what was happening.
And I can find that, well, looks
like full screen activity is
doing something bad.
It's calling a lot of string
builder stuff with text view.
We also have a way to show
that as a sunburst chart.
So if I invoke that, you can see
we get this little nice chart
below here.
And I can sort by, for
example, size or count.
And we also have this
other layout representation
of the data.
So you can use
this and basically
drill over to see what's going
on with your allocations.
We can also grab a heap
dump from your app.
Or maybe one of your
customer sends you one,
and, you know, you
can ask for this,
if you want to find
out what's going on.
So you no longer have to
convert your H profiles.
We read them directly now.
And so all have to do
is click it to open it.
And-- let me get
myself some more room,
I'm using really large
font so you can see.
So, here we have
several columns.
And the most
important one, maybe,
is the retained size column.
So if I sort by descending
order of retained size,
this is telling me the
cumulative amount of memory
I could save if I could
get rid of these objects.
So here you can see we
have a lot of bitmaps,
and when I select
the class, I get
an instance view on the right.
In here we're using the
debugger UI to basically--
you could now inspect
objects from the heap dump
as if you're debugging them
and look at the values.
That perhaps the most
important part here
is the reference tree below.
So this is showing you all
the incoming references
to this object.
And we're always
sorting it so that's
the nearest garbage collection
root is the first field.
So look what happens.
When I start expanding
the first child here.
You see the depth column?
This is counting down
to the nearest GC root,
as I'm going down.
And so here I found it.
Basically, this is
the static instance
that is causing all the chain
of pointers to my object
and keeping in memory.
So if you have a memory leak,
and you want to get rid of it,
or if you're wondering where's
most the memory coming,
this is an, I think,
an invaluable tool.
And this is now available
in the 1.3 preview.
[APPLAUSE]
All right, let's talk
about Developer Services.
So first of all,
let me just show you
that I'm logged into
my Google account,
in the upper right corner.
That's going to become
relevant in a second.
So I can open up the project
structure dialogue here,
and you could see the modulus
that you're used to seeing,
it's now below this new
developer services section.
So here we're integrating
various developer services.
So for example,
there's GCM, there's
authentication,
analytics, and ads.
Most of these are just adding a
dependency on the Play Services
library.
But we've fleshed out
the analytics integration
in a bit more detail.
So now I can, basically,
say that I want
to add analytics to my project.
When I do that, because
I'm logged in-- otherwise
it would say please
login first--
it's now made a connection to
the Google Analytics console.
It's pulling down the
Google analytics projects
associated with my account.
I can choose it.
It fetches the right tracker ID.
And when I say, OK, it
now goes and creates
this analytics tracker
class in my project.
This is very similar to the
code that you would find online
if you go to Google
Analytics documentation that
says what to do.
It also creates a
app tracker file
which records the tracker
ID for my project.
Please don't use it.
And so now there's this
class that, you then,
will have to initialize
from your context.
And of course the
callback to whenever you
want to record an
analytics event.
So this is something we're
planning to do a lot more of.
We're going to build out
more services, and so forth.
But we think this is a
pretty useful start, so let
us know how this works for you.
We've also done
something to help
you stay up to date on all
the SDK components that we're
releasing.
So in the past, with
the old SDK manager,
you had to regularly
open it and see,
is there anything new for me?
Well, we're now using
the same mechanism
that we push IDE
notifications up to,
to also notify that
there's new SDK components.
So here it's telling
me, hey, there's
a new M preview platform.
And I can now click
to use the ID patching
mechanism to update this.
We've also ported
the SDK manager,
so that it's not fully
integrated with IDE
with, sort of, a
newer fresher-- yes
[APPLAUSE]
--I agree.
A new fresh IDE-- UI
on it that I can then
use to install stuff.
And so hopefully this
will make it easier
to stay up to date with all the
stuff that we are releasing.
OK, so everything
I've showed you today
is going to be in 1.3.
Now it turns out the C++ support
is not in the first preview.
It's-- we didn't make it, but
it'll be in the next couple
weeks-- next couple weeks, it'll
be in the next preview build.
But everything else I've
showed you is in 1.3 preview.
Now I'm going to show you
a couple of things they're
coming in upcoming versions.
So the first thing
is the Theme Editor.
So this is the styles at XML
file for the I/O scheduling
application.
Right?
It's pretty complicated.
And this is just one of
four overloaded files.
So we now have a Theme Editor.
Well will have-- we have a
prototype-- we're working on
it-- have a Theme Editor, which
basically takes select data,
analyzes it-- Yeah,
you're allowed to clap.
[APPLAUSE]
You could see this, basically,
analyzes the projects,
figures out what's going on.
I can choose between
different themes here.
And I can also make edits.
So it's showing me
here, for example,
that I have a state list
here-- the checkerboard is
trying to show the alpha
value of the color.
It's showing me how the
colors were resolved.
And perhaps, most importantly,
I can use this to, actually,
tweak the colors.
So if I open up a
color chooser here--
oh this screen resolution
is not helping--
you can see that as I'm
tweaking the colors,
I can see a live preview
of what these widgets will
look like with that color.
This should make it a lot
easier to tweak your themes.
All right last but not
least, the Layout Editor.
We are working to
completely rewrite it,
with a lot of new features.
So it's early days
still, but one
of the things we're
working on is possibly
having a blueprint
mode for your layout.
So you can, sort of,
see what's going on.
And you can, sort of, work
in both modes the same time.
We're integrating the
Google design library.
So for example, I can
drag an app bar layout
on to this layout.
And so-- oh, I shouldn't have
changed the color to red.
That looks so ugly.
All right, anyway, I'm
now going to go and pull
in, for example, a--
didn't I have a--
what's the name of the logo?
Yeah, there it is.
I can pull in an I/O
logo, which doesn't really
work with the red, but fine.
And also a floating action
button, which is also red.
And when I choose this, you get
this beautiful UI right here.
You see it before and after.
[APPLAUSE]
So we've had the XML
preview mode for awhile,
whereas you can
mostly work in XML
and sort of see what's
going on the right.
And we've expanded that recently
so that you can now use it
for System Preferences as well.
So this is a system
preference file
and it's just rendered the
way the UI is going to look.
But one important
improvement now
is that this is no
longer a preview window.
This is the Layout Editor.
So I can go over here and
even if-- while editing
I can, instead, go over
start dragging things around
and make edits.
I can even pull in the
pallet right here locally.
The minute I start dragging
the pallet goes away,
and I'm editing the layout.
So that's the Layout Editor.
And, you know, I'm
not sure exactly when
it's going to be done.
But hopefully--
hopefully not too long.
All right, with that, I'm going
to turn it back over to Jay
to wrap up.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMAL EASON: So
great-- great demos.
So what's next?
I guess before digging
into the specific features,
I think it might be helpful
to understand how we actually
developed Android Studio.
So you've probably seen
these release channels
and are thinking about what
do these channels even mean?
For us we have a series
release channels.
So today we're
launching 1.3 preview
in Canary, which means it's,
sort of, the first release.
So then every couple weeks we do
a series of tests and feedback.
And then we promote those
releases all the way
through Dev, Beta.
and to finally the Stable.
And throughout that process,
we get your feedback.
So if you want to
see if something
is broken or something
needs to be fixed,
we actually look at
the feedback to make
sure it reaches
the Stable channel
when we release the final
version of Android Studio.
So looking forward, today
we did 1.3 and we're
looking at some 1.4, 1.5
features today at the demo.
And so if you think
about it, basically,
most of our odd releases are
or more focused on features.
And then or even
releases are more
focused on the polished
aspect of the ID.
So again, kind of
looking at what's next.
So Xav talked
about the Emulator.
So we're definitely-- we
know we have some work to do,
and we're definitely
going to focus on that
and making sure it's a great
performing experience for you
to do to your local testing on.
As Tor mentioned, we're also
really working on the Developer
Service Integration.
Where we're initially adding the
Google services into that flow.
But we're also opening up
to other third party tools,
because we know you use
a lot of different tools,
we want to make it easy for you
to integrate that your project.
And then last thing
I want to mention
in my previous slide--
it's about the Polish
and Performance.
Really making sure that we
provide a great experience
for you-- this is a
part of the flow for us
in the Android Studio team.
Great.
And that's it.
[APPLAUSE]
So please leave feedback for us.
We're also having office
hours today from four to five,
at the end of the day.
And I think it's
going to be, actually,
on that side of building.
And then again, leave
feedback for us in the app
or on the website.
So we have, maybe, three or
four minutes for some questions.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Before we start
questions, we also have today
and tomorrow some box talks
throughout the Playground.
There some about testing.
There's one about the
Profiler-- the Memory Profiler.
So check the
schdule-- they are--
usually they're repeated twice.
So you can check it when
it's convenient for you.
TOR NORBYE: And
I think they also
wanted us to say that after
this we will be outside,
so don't talk to
us by the stage.
We're supposed to go outside
for a follow up questions.
All right.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Question.
AUDIENCE: So earlier
you mentioned
automating install of
HEXM Is there any option
to automate the setting of
the BIOS setting in Windows
necessary enable that?
XAVIER DUCROHET:
I think would be--
JAMAL EASON: So if we
notice in your BIOS
that you don't have
it set, we actually
give you a warning about,
hey, you need to update that.
So 1.3 is actually now
a prompt to tell you
that you need to, actually,
set that your BIOS.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Any
thoughts on Java 1.8?
XAVIER DUCROHET: Java 8?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
XAVIER DUCROHET: No.
Java 8--
TOR NORBYE: Is that
what comes after seven?
XAVIER DUCROHET: It's a
platform issue, right?
It's like you have to
talk to the platforms.
AUDIENCE: OK.
XAVIER DUCROHET: But
we don't have anything
to say about that.
AUDIENCE: Has there been any
changes to the NDK Build Model?
Are we still relying on
Android.MK and all that stuff?
XAVIER DUCROHET: So the
integration in Gradle
will replace the Android.MK.
Gradle has Native Support
to handle Native code.
All you have to do is tell
Gradle where the two chain is
so it will, basically, do
the bridge between the two
a chain of the NDK are here.
And then we tell Gradle
use those two chains
and compile it.
TOR NORBYE: That's
the main reason
why we couldn't include
in the first preview-- is
we were still wanting that
experimental plug-in to be
hooked up.
Because we really don't want
to continue that all the way.
AUDIENCE: You know the
issue with the unit tests
on the instrumentation
test-- both being on the path
at the same time?
You had to switch the flavor
to get them on the path?
XAVIER DUCROHET: In Studio?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yeah
we're working on that.
AUDIENCE: So-- it's
with a separate module?
Does that mean they're
both on at the same time
if you move things
from one module?
XAVIER DUCROHET: Well you
would-- yeah-- because it's
just a different module.
The issue is that Studio does
not have a concept of, like,
to test cope that are separate.
So we're working on
figuring something out.
But if use a test
module, then you
could unit test in you main
module, and a separate module,
and that would work.
AUDIENCE: OK, great.
XAVIER DUCROHET: All
right, probably-- alright--
AUDIENCE: One last?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Really excited about
the H profile analysis stuff.
Is that thing--
the code itself--
is that going to be open
source, and is the UI code
separated from the thing
that does the analysis?
XAVIER DUCROHET:
Yeah, all the UI--
I mean everything except for
Native-- all stuff in Studio
is open source, so it in there.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
XAVIER DUCROHET: All
right, thank you everyone.
We'll be over there, so if
you have more questions,
we'll answer them.
Thank you.
JAMAL EASON: Thank you.